او مع تداول اخبار الزلزال ومستجدات
عمليات الانقاذ واعداد الضحايا واخبار
الزلازل الجديده كمان لسه الناس بتدور على
النظريات تفسر فيها اللي صار في حلقه امس
ناقشنا بعض النظريات اللي الناس جالسه
بتعملها او على الاقل بتساءل يعني بتتساءل
عنها او بخصوصها مثل توقف لب الارض عن
الدوران وعلاقته بالزلزال او تصرفات غريبه
لبعض الحيوانات والزلزال او مرور المذنب
الاخضر بالقرب من الارض لاول مره من 50
سنه وعلاقته بزلزال والملفت انه يعني رغم
انه في علماء كثار بينفوا اي علاقات بين
هذه الامور
والزلازل لكن في ناس ثانيه شايفه العكس
تماما وما بتكلم هنا عن ناس عاديه انا
بتكلم عن مختصين وخبراء وعلماء اناس دارسه
مو ناس بتقول رايها يعني فمثلا في ناس
مصره ان المذنب له علاقه بالزلزال وبيتاكد
انه هو السبب وبتقول كمان انه هذا تفسير
عدد الزلازل الكبيره اللي صارت وسمعنا
عنها من وقت الزلزال المدمر للان في ناس
تانيه شايفه ان الاحتباس الحراري والتغير
المناخي له علاقه باللي يصير وزياده
الزلازل بسبب هذه الامور تحديدا ولو ما
عملنا شيء في الزلازل والكوارث حتزيد اكثر
واكثر خلينا نسمع راي دكتور دومه كامل
رئيس حزب البيئه العالمي اهلا فيك معنا
دكتور دومه خليني
اهلا انا لما كنت بتكلم معاك قبل الهوى
حضرتك مؤمن بنظريه ارتباط المذنب
وعلاقته بالزلزال اللي حصلوا انه متسبب
مباشره في هذا الامر اذا ممكن تشرح لنا
هذا الموضوع لانه مختلف عليه جدا
اولا السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
نتقدم باحر التعازي من اهالي الضحايا اللي
سقطوا
عظم الله اجرهم وان شاء الله بتكون بتكون
نهايه الاحزان على سطح الكوكب ولكن متل ما
كان عم بحكي اليوم اليوم لعلماء العلماء
اللي بيفكروا مزبوط واللي بيبحثوا واللي
عندهم بحث تاريخي عن هذا الموضوع بيقدروا
يوصلوا يعرفوا الحقيقه اين هي اليوم بدنا
نبلش من التاريخ الصيني والتاريخ الفارسي
والتاريخ العربي والتاريخ اللي من 3000
سنه لليوم يلي بينحكى فيه عن ما يعرف بنجم
ابو ذنب كانوا يقولوا نجم ابو ذنب بده
يقطع في كانوا عندنا ما بينحكى عن وصول
مذنب ما معين على صدد بالقرب من كوكب
الارض او المشاهده بالعين المجرده كانوا
يقولوا فورا انه جاي العوائل جايه الزلازل
جايه الفيضانات جايه الحروب كانوا خافوا
كتير
ولكن اليوم بدي اقول اصحاب العلم بيعرفوا
الحقيقه اكثر اليوم نحن انا شخصيا متاكد
من دخول كوكب من دخول المذنب الاخضر
حوالي
للقرب من المجموعه الشمسيه
وتاثيره الخطير جدا بكل تاكيد انكتب من
شهر او من 25 يوم شو راح تعمل بالارض
يا ايها النجم النجم الاخضر كان جوابي كان
جوابي التالي بكل تاكيد زلازل وهزيت ارضيه
وفيضانات
لانه الكوكب ايوه
الرابط كل كوكب مهما يكون عنده طاقته
الجاذبيه عنده طاقته الجاذبيه طاقه
الجاذبيه اللي بده يشتغل عليها والجاذبيه
بين الكواكب الى دور كثير كبير بحركه
بحركه بحركه الطبقات التكتونيه بضمن ضمن
الكواكب
بتاول اول حدث صار انه كان في تاثير شاب
بشكل مباشر على الحركه التكتونيه الموجوده
يلي ادت الى زلزال خطير جدا دمر منطقه
بشكل كامل اثنين
وين صار شو صار يعني
ما كانت تسير في ارتباط الارضيه والزلازل
في اماكن كان في عندنا بروسيه بروسيه
زلزال بقوه 5.درجات بجزر 5.2 درجه
بكازختين كازاخستان 4.7 درجات على الحدود
الصينيه كمان هزه
اربع فاصله خمس درجات كمان بالمتن الشمالي
بلبنان
غزه صارت ثلاثه
عدد الزلازل في هذا الوقت تحديدا مرتبطه
بمرور المذنب في هذا الوقت تحديدا
انا بسال قبل بس بسال السؤال التالي خلينا
ما نفكر هيك ليه من ثلاثه اشهر ما كانوا
موجودين الليله عند مسار زلزال تركيا
وبنفس ثلاثه ايام
صاروا مع العلم انه بمنطقه شارع اذا اخذنا
زلزال لبنان وزلزل نابلس لا يرتبطان مطلقا
بزلزل تركيا من هون بنكون عرفنا الحقيقه
العلميه طيب الدكتور انت عارف انه في كثير
ناس بيخلفوك في هذه النظريه وبيقولوا انه
ما في شيء اي علمي بيثبت هذا الكلام
نحن عم نحكي علم نحن عم نحكي علم انه
يعرفوا يعرفوا درجه طاقه الجاذبيه من كل
كوكب موجود بدي اعطي شكله واضح لو القمر
عنا هون القمر الكوكب الكوكب القريب لالنا
لو ما كان عنده الجزبيه شو كانت حياه
الارض انا بدي اسال سؤال تاني جاوبوني اذا
الامر ما عنده الجاذبيه شو حياه الارض اذا
الكواكب الاخرى اللي ما عندهم معلومات عن
الكواكب ودرجه الجاذبيه بكل كوكب وحركه
الجاذبيه بين الكواكب ما بيقدروا يحكوا بس
قبل
ما ينتهي الوقت بس دكتور كنت حابه اسالك
كمان على موضوع التغير المناخي هل في اي
رابط بينه وبين ما يحدث الان من زلازل
بكل تاكيد لا تغير المناخي شيء اخر تغير
المناخي هو يتاثر تتاثر الكتل الهوائيه
بحراره عاليه وبوجود غازات دفيئه بشكل
عالي ولكن لا تاثير مطلقا على الزلازل من
تغير المناخير الان المناخي
المزيد من الزلازل او خلاص بما انه يعني
اخر الشهر
تاثيره على على الكوكب راح يضل لاخر الشهر
وان شاء الله ما يكون عنا درجه درجه زلازل
بالنسبه بنسبه عاليه جدا تكون درجات بسيطه
مثل ما صار بنابلس متل ما صار بالمتن ومتل
ما صار على كازاخستان وعلى حدود الصين
واماكن اخرى ان شاء الله ما تكون ما تكون
درجه الخطوره اكثر من هيك ولكن بدي حزر
وبدي شدد على نقطة كتير مهمه المفروض دول
العالم كلها بتاخد تاخد القرار السليم جدا
وهو اذا نحن مستعدين نقدمه مجانا لكل دول
العالم
دراسه جديده جدا
ومعلومات عن كل مدينه درجه الامنيه اللي
فيها قد ايه بتتحمل هالزيت وقد ايه بتتحمل
درجه خطورتها هل في ابنيه بتتحمل سبع
درجات اوت من درجات هزه او كل هون بتحملوا
اكثر
في عاجل موجود على قناه العربيه الان يعني
انه اردوغان او الرئيس التركي بيقول انه
لم يكن ممكن الاستعداد لكارثه بهذه
الضخامه
نوعيه الدراسات اللي بتتحدث عنها
حضرتك بتخالفه
ممكن الاستعداد ممكن نعمل الاستعداد
لدراسات شامله مطلق بالمستقبل انه تكون كل
مدننا كل بكل قرانا هي
الابنيه الموجوده فيها تتحمل درجه زلازل
عاليه مثل ما وصلت اليابان اليابان دوله
وامريكا المتحده الامريكيه وغسلوا لعندهم
عندهم عندهم ابنيه تتحمل تتحمل درجات
تتحمل زلازل بقوه درجات تسع درجات على
مقياس رختر في حال وضعت استراتيجيه لكل
الدول تنفذ
الابنيه بنفس المواصفات بنكون نحن امنا
لجيل مستقبلي جيل مستقبلي ما عنده ما عنده
اي خوف من الزلازل القادمه وهيدا الموضوع
لازم يكون على محمل جد ضمن جامعه الدول
العربيه ودون نضم للمنطقه العربيه من اجل
وضع استراتيجيات جديده من قضيه الوضع
جهوزيه جديده للتعامل للتعامل مع الكوارث
انا بدي اقول انه اليوم في حال حصل كوارث
بمناطق ما معينه ما عندهم الجهوزي ما عنده
الخطط المواجهه ما عنده المعدات المطلوبه
وبكل تاكيد راح يدفع الشعب العربي اسماء
غاليه ولكن بدي بدي شدد على نقطه مجلس
التعاون الخليجي عنده جهوزيه وعندهم
استراتيجيه وعندهم عمل جده جدا نتمنى من
الدول العربيه الاخرى انه يكون عندها
ونفس الاستعداد وبدي اتقدم بالشكر كتير
كبير لكل المنطقه العربيه اللي بلشت تقدم
مساعدات مساعدات لا
للناجين والمساعدات للمناطق المنكوبه طبعا
هذا التاريخ العربي بيشهد على الكرم وعلى
فعل الخير وعلى المحبه والاخوه تحيه مني
وبس بالبيئه العالم وباسمي الف كلمه شكر
طيب بنشكرك على هذه المداخله كان معنا من
بيروت دكتور ضمت كامل رئيس حزب البيئه
العالمي شكرا لك